I have a question um well actually not
just one I have all the questions Toy
Story and wreck-it Ralph are two of our
most favorite Pixar films but have you
ever noticed how much these two movies
have in common
keep watching to find out exactly how
these films are connected Toy Story
exists and Ralph breaks the Internet
the first major way we see these two
movies intertwine actually happens and
Ralph breaks the Internet
vanellope ends up on the oh my Disney
section of the Internet and things get
very meta it's here that we find out
that basically everything Disney exists
in the world of wreck-it Ralph the oh my
Disney scene is basically Disney
Inception there are so many Easter eggs
it's impossible to notice all of them he
is groups I am vanellope click here
that's why you probably didn't notice a
very familiar face in the crowd that's
right Buzz Lightyear makes a very brief
appearance on the screen he's there for
barely a second but he is definitely
there he is dancing in front of a giant
Mickey Mouse head of course he might be
familiar with the Pixar theory by John
Negroni basically the theory suggests
that all Pixar movies exists in the same
cinematic universe and the evidence is
pretty convincing this doesn't make any
sense
Disney has basically confirmed it - they
released a video showing a whole bunch
of Pixar Easter eggs and then John
Lasseter from the Toy Story franchise
told us some even bigger news Toy Story
4 is going to have more Pixar Easter
eggs than any other Pixar film whoa it's
hard to imagine a movie with more Pixar
hence than Ralph breaks the internet we
can't wait to see if Ralph and vanellope
end up in the new Toy Story movie
character links the connection between
record Ralph and Toy Story is super deep
this has a lot more to do with the plot
and the characters then with Easter eggs
themselves because well some of the
characters in the record Ralph's movies
seem really familiar let's take a look
at vanilla pee first
so he was spying on me when ralph first
meets vanellope he's not that impressed
Penelope is loud and demanding and she
totally gets on Ralph's last nerve
but eventually she wins him over they
bond of her being outcasts from other
games and soon they are BFFs does
vanellope remind you of anyone that's
right she sounds a lot like Jessie from
Toy Story 2 when we first meet Jessie
she is pretty annoying at least that's
what woody thinks she's excited to be
reunited with him she's loud and
dramatic and kind of bossy but she and
woody soon become really great friends
they bond over their antique status and
woody realizes that she has a great
heart the characters similarities don't
stop there let's take a look at ralph
and woody at first glance you might
think they have nothing in common but
they are actually both dealing with
similar issues what he's upset in the
first Toy Story movie because he thinks
he is no longer Andy's toy he gets all
angsty as he tries to figure out his
place in the world
now that Buzz Lightyear is around he
binds with the rest of the matching
antique toys in Toy Story 2 over being
unwanted this all feels very familiar
Ralph just feels like he doesn't fit in
he isn't appreciated in the video game
world because he's a villain but he
doesn't want to be a villain anymore he
tries a bond with a villain support
group and he's totally afraid of being
unplugged because he would totally lose
his purpose
woody feels the same way he is scared of
being unwanted Ralph and woody also had
to deal with the hot new things in their
world for woody this toy is Buzz
Lightyear he's fancy and advanced in the
world of wreck-it Ralph the new thing
appears in a couple of different ways
there's a sergeant Calhoun alien
invasion game in the first movie but
Ralph doesn't see that game as much of a
threat a better analogy to buzz is in
Ralph's brixi Internet Penelope
discovers a totally epic racing game
called slaughter race and Ralph
immediately thinks it's all bad he
doesn't want to lose his bestie to the
game that's exactly how Andy felt about
woody the flat connections imagine a
story about an outcast they are losing
their purpose they have a great cast of
characters around them they have a
trusty sidekick who they might not like
much at first they go on a great
adventure
I'm sure there's someone out here could
give us directions save the day and find
their purpose along the way it sounds
familiar right
in fact it sounds like almost every
Pixar movie ever Toy Story and wreck-it
Ralph aren't the only two movies with
this plot it happens in Finding Nemo a
bug's life cars and Monsters Inc and
that's just a few of them but Pixar
always makes this familiar story feel so
new and that basic storyline is just so
relatable all good toys have gone on to
new owners if it isn't broke don't fix
it right from the first Pixar film to
the most recent one we see this
happening over and over again and when
you look at wreck-it Ralph it feels a
lot like Toy Story the characters have a
ton in common both woody and Ralph have
to go on a big adventure to save the day
and end up finding themselves in the
process why are they so connected we
know they fit in the same universe but
how we're talking toys and sentient
video game characters even a thing both
movies have things that come to life
when humans aren't around one theory
suggests that it's the same sort of
magic that causes this to happen one
Reddit user suggests that maybe this is
the love of a child
kids love toys and arcade games we
totally love this idea
the fact that some magic makes fake
things real is pretty cool and if it is
a child's love a lot of stuff makes
sense
what do use tariff I dove no longer
being wanted by Andy Ralph doesn't want
his game to get unplugged maybe they are
driven by some deep instinct that tells
them they can't exist without a child's
love that's actually super deep and we
can't help but feel like it makes a
whole lot of sense so what do you think
makes these characters come to life how
else are Pixar movies connected tell us
your theories in the comments get out of
here the world's waiting for your kid
give this video a big thumbs up if you
love Pixar movies and for more videos
like this one hit that subscribe button
thanks for watching the things we'll see
you next time
[Music]